ils ne seront pas athlètes olympiques en
2024 mais en seront très certainement
spectateurs 180 années-luminois ont pu
profiter de générations champion une
après-midi de sport organisée par Cisco
l'un des partenaires des JO au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il
y a beaucoup d'activités
on s'amuse on profite et on donne tout
le meilleur des nous-même sachant qu'il
y a des récompenses à la fin j'ai
préféré le tir à l'arc parce que c'est
vrai c'est très dur
on peut découvrir des nouveaux sports on
a pu voir des athlètes de haut niveau
que parce que aux JO et c'est très bien
ces athlètes de haut niveau les
champions du monde de 110 mètres et en
2005 et Vincent Luis triathlète multiple
champion du monde et médaillés de bronze
en relais mixte lors des dernières
Olympiades la génération avait grandi et
on espère que grâce à cet événement il
deviendront des grandes des grandes
personnes et du coup bah il faut il faut
aller à des endroits qui font la
promotion de ce genre d'événement
personnellement voilà que c'est agrandir
mon sport moi le créateur
transmettre aux jeunes cette passion du
sport et cette passion d'être dehors et
on a la chance pour pour les athlètes
français comme moi d'avoir les jeux à la
maison c'est des choses qui arrivent
très très peu dans une carrière ce sera
mes 4e jeu moi et voilà j'aimerais bien
que ça se finisse vraiment en apothéose
avec un bon résultat l'événement a fait
étape samedi 18 mars s'il était destiné
aux enfants de 8 à 16 ans participent à
des activités olympiques et
paralympiques nous disons pas forcément
l'habitude de participer il y a du
tennis fauteuil voilà c'est vraiment
promotion aussi du handisport et puis
voilà la visite aussi de de ce site
futur site olympique le Stadium BMX
aussi des initiations et des challenges
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines étaient l'une
des quatre étapes de l'événement
prochain rendez-vous Nice le 1er avril
non